i got tom curran who just popped up and
looks like
wait time do you you look like you were
frustrated or angry or what yes
what they did this last year let's go
again i mean they did this they came up
with the ridiculous assertion that
franco harris in the immaculate
reception
was the greatest player in nfl but
that's not in a super bowl
right which is bizarre to even contend
that it was because clearly it's the
malcolm butler interception it happens
at the end of the game the tyree thing
with 13 other things that had to happen
after that play i mean it's the
buckwheat thing yeah i agree
that's what i would say but i'm just so
mad at mclovin
why just his contention and he's got a
better head on his shoulders than this
and it's disappointing to see him
in decline wow yes mclovin by the way i
just want to make sure your fan base
knows uh
nick foles is uh going against tom brady
tonight uh who won that super bowl tom
uh that would be the eagles won that
super bowl because malcolm butler was
consigned to the bench
uh the official the official
introduction tom curran the patriots
insider for nbc sports boston
like when do you become an insider like
you go from a reporter
to an insider is that is there something
that happens that all of a sudden
definitely a good question and there's a
point in which you're peripheral guy
and so you go from reporter to straight
reporter then peripheral guy
periphery guy and then you're an insider
um and there's just there's
certifications that you have to go
through
um that i think that you know i'd love
to get into now but it's more detailed
than we really have the time for but
i'm in there i'm kind of a patriots
outsider
i know you are yeah hashtag mommy yeah
hashtag tommy when's last time you
communicated with
tom brady uh the camp you know how we
like to do that
i rode my horse past the camp this week
um
he was in his tv didn't get a chance to
say hello um
but yeah the camp i usually stay in in
steady communication with really yeah
it's funny i mean you've
you've communicated with brady over the
years i would imagine
hashtag i try to keep that quiet
i don't like that put that out there let
everybody go oh you must know him i just
what i do in my private life is it's
called private time
same thing with the insidery stuff yeah
i want to let you know how i got
the here but what but what questions do
you have
for brady now that you'd be curious
about
how much better is the tampa bay
offensive experience right now with the
players you're surrounded by than the
final year of
the new england patriots or the final
two years of the new england patriots
and is there any wistful looking up at
new england
and saying wow i i kind of miss it up
there i would guess
the answer to the latter is no no no no
this worked out perfectly for everybody
involved and the animosity while
somewhat there is not great enough that
it damaged anything long term
what do you think what would you ask i
think that's i think that's the the
place that i would start
is how different is the experience there
and is it what you thought
it was going to be uh how
how many games how often do you check on
what the patriots do
how curious are you what teammates do
you stay in con
when do you want me to stop there
insider i mean you know what no
that's fine there was an interesting
juncture in the game the other day where
um brady had to take a timeout or a
penalty
because and he got yelled at from the
sideline and if there were fans in the
stands you wouldn't have heard this
but he had to take a timeout or they
took a penalty either way the clock ran
out
um and someone yelled to him just
snapped the ball
and he yelled at the sideline he was
still bleeping moving
no one really picked up on that but i
think that his patience right now
seems to be paper thin in general as he
gets older as yours did too at the tel
the fellows have told me yes and i'm in
i'm in decline as well
uh cam's status for this weekend is
i honestly wish i could have a glib
answer for you or even an accurate
answer
the fact that we don't know whether or
not he's been tested and tested negative
yet makes it impossible for me to give a
clear answer
so i can't i don't even want to guess um
i guess the better question is whether
there's a game or not
what do you think there will be a game i
don't think there will be a game
and i tried to pin belichick down this
morning on what do you need to prepare
when you look at the patriots had their
monday erased and played a football game
had their tuesday erased by the commute
home
and then have had wednesday and thursday
erased by not being able to be in the
facility
you have physical treatments that need
to go on you have
scouting and preparation needs to go on
you have two quarterbacks who have yet
to take a practice rep
in advance of playing either of these
two games it's going to be a point of
which you say you know what
this isn't really what we're trying to
put out as a product is it
what about stefan gilmore same thing and
it's interesting you know adam schefter
spoke on philadelphia radio
uh about having heard that gilmore and
newton
dined together last friday night now
that was in advance of cam
learning that he was covered positive so
it's not a transgression necessarily
that they died together
but this amplifies the fact that gilmore
didn't test positive until wednesday
so you can incubate over that period of
time we'll find out whether anybody on
that close contact plane
was infected but i would imagine gilmore
i'd have to answer the same way
dana unless i know if he's had a
negative test and he's asymptomatic
i can't answer when do you think the nfl
is going to let the patriots and broncos
know because it feels like we're
everybody's all in on what's going on
with the titans and bills
and and that is in jeopardy it you know
they're not
you're saying they may not play or you
don't think they will whereas
now we're hearing diana rossini said
they might move that game to monday
uh for the bills and the titans
so any when does the nfl have to
inform these teams well i mean denver
would fly on saturday
and coming west to east you they'd have
to fly a little earlier in the day
i think yeah earlier in the day because
so um really they'd have to let them
know in the next
24 to 36 hours stan right if you yeah if
even that
i would think i'd need to know by friday
i think to be fair to
these teams you know just trying to
prepare for a football game
it's hard enough to prepare now you're
going we can't even go to the facility
to prepare
and that's what's really hard for the
patriots and i know there's not gonna be
a lot of tears shed but when you look at
okay they
there are only three positive tests
right now but the timing of them
and the fact that they traveled are what
are the existential facts
extended factors that enter into this
stand so
you know i spoke to somebody with the
league guests and they said you know
well atlanta played after they i said
you know and i know it we had didn't fly
so don't bring up atlanta the patriots
flew
after having a positive test and we'll
see what the ramifications are
i wondered when i was watching kansas
city and you know hoyer and stidham came
in i thought belichick
did a great job in what he wanted to do
with the defense there
and you know if you had a con you know a
decent
quarterback in there the running game
would have kept
patrick mahomes off the field like they
had the blueprint there um
you know you you're around this team i'm
i was just curious if cam had played in
that game
given this blueprint that they have do
you think the patriots would have beaten
the chiefs
yeah i think that they would have beaten
the chiefs i mean they end up losing by
16 points there's a pick six that
um it's just a horrible play i don't
know if they would have been a position
to have that happen
the points taken off the board by bad
decisions by
by hoyer and uh physical lapse by hoya
you you have to say that it would have
looked differently the first pick that
the patriots threw
would have looked differently i think as
you point out perfectly
the running game would have been that
much more effective with another factor
in the mix
and the defensive game plan was uh
impenetrable impenetrable good
uh you know it's one of it's one of the
longest running debates
in sports show history uh i think you've
weighed in on this
julian edelman hall of famer oh hot dog
i thought it's hot dog sandwich
no no no no no uh yeah julian edelman's
a hall of famer if lynn swann's sitting
in there
and joe namath's sitting in there you
got to put julian edelman in there
and game is changing okay you know what
can i just back that off and just say he
needs to be in a conversation
is that too hedgy well
yeah i know i would let you get by with
that you have to
i mean you did backpedal a little too
fast there
it's well in the hall of fame look when
swan is in there
based primarily on his super bowl
performances
and julian edelman's playoff
performances are so absurd and his
iconic plays are so absurd
that when we talk about art monk or
isaac bruce or these guys who compiled
numbers over the years but never had
monumental plays this is the other side
of the coin
you know gail sayers was not in the
league forever
but he was an icon an iconic unique
player who was emblematic of something
and i think edelman has been as well of
the second half of the patriots dynasty
yeah but at that position things have
changed dramatically
and and while i'll give you that with
swanny and what he did in the super bowl
absolutely and john stalworth but you
know that was as balanced
of a team as we've probably ever seen in
in the nfl
you know their defense they ran the ball
and uh
you know you had great wide receivers
there but they didn't ask them to do
that
um and i think nowadays you got to have
a thousand receptions at least to be in
a conversation to be in the hall of fame
it's like a running back if i'm going to
compare running backs now to
jim taylor with the green bay packers
then
they're if i say adrian peterson jim
taylor are you going to go
of course adrian peterson look at the
numbers he put frank gore
to uh jim taylor of the packard right
what's the difference between jim taylor
and frank gore
the postseason performances which on the
highest and most
you know highly leveraged positions and
times
using with a quarterback though i don't
know how much the quarterback helped him
during the catch again no no but i'm
saying that the quarterback we look at
your postseason numbers
that's where we elevate you to great
price unless you have
unparalleled performances in multiple
postseason games and
edelman kind of did i mean but he hasn't
been a pro bowler has he been at one
time maybe
yeah if if that but i mean again that's
that's the byproduct of people voting
based upon okay
he doesn't play the same position as
deandre hopkins or julio jones it's a
different position the same way
third down back is different from
running back
and i think you have to allow for that
to some degree
i just think that he's it's basically
you can't tell the story
about the nfl without julian edelman and
leave it at that
and i think that we get too far into the
uh how the hell do we get on edelman
oh no it's been a conversa it comes up
periodically when we'll go
would you rather have calvin johnson's
career or julian edelman and
then then we have the discussion i think
we brought up
julio jones or julian edelman whose
career would you want to have
probably julio jones it seems like more
fun and i'm probably going to be able to
have more fun on the golf course when
i'm 55
60. i just don't think julian i mean
he's just taking a thrashing
no i don't care what you know if i'm
walking at 40.
i'm just talking about now well i'd
probably rather have
i'd probably rather have edelman's
career yeah i would too
i mean you had the biggest moments a
couple of the biggest catches in the
history of the super bowl
and julio jones had a
great catch in the super bowl but they
didn't win
so leo's never winning a parade i mean
the games lead to the parades parades
are terrific
what's the book over your shoulder oh
that's a book that i did with julian
edelman
yeah yeah yeah the mr objectivity
you're a knucklehead all right i'll let
you go back to being an insider there
so uh thank you thank you uh for sharing
your insights with us
we had a good time thanks all right
that's that's tom curran
tom e curran he's an insider